Jake:哈哈小嘟嘟
Jake: Haha, little Dudu
Jake:好难呐
Jake: It's so hard
Jake:要不咱先下去戴眼镜
Jake: How about we go down and put on the glasses first
Jake:然后录一段喊他的镜头
Jake: Then record a shot of calling him
Jake:呃你的眼睛就在下面
Jake: Uh, your glasses are down there
Jake:然后可以开一下
Jake: Then you can turn it on
Jake:好你的眼镜戴在台灯上哈
Jake: Okay, your glasses are on the lamp
Jake:然后戴一下好
Jake: Then put them on, alright
Jake:在楼上走走
Jake: Let's walk upstairs
Jake:我们上楼
Jake: We're going upstairs
Jake:我们上楼执行任务
Jake: We're going upstairs to complete the task
Jake:我们执行任务
Jake: We're completing the task
Jake:我没有我没有把薇薇叫起来
Jake: I didn't wake Tasha up
Jake:然后露亚也没有叫起来
Jake: And I didn't wake Lucia up either
Jake:所以我们要齐心协力一起把
Jake: So we need to work together to
Alice:他没醒
Alice: He didn't wake up
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know
Jake:我打电话他也没有接
Jake: I called him but he didn't answer
Lucia: 有可能是没醒
Lucia: He might still be asleep
Lucia: 因为应该不会在外面
Lucia: Because he probably wouldn't be outside
Jake:有可能是睡对
Jake: He might be sleeping, right
Lucia: 对但是反正我刚敲了几次门
Lucia: Yeah, but anyway, I knocked a few times
Lucia: 但是好像没醒
Lucia: But it seems like he's still asleep
Jake:凭什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: Why is that, hahaha
Alice:该戴眼镜了
Alice: Time to put on the glasses
Lucia: 这就是见证奇迹的时刻
Lucia: This is the moment to witness a miracle
Jake:凭什么呀
Jake: Why is that
Alice:你收拾一下起来吧
Alice: Get up and tidy up
Alice:OK了充电宝呢
Alice: OK, where's the power bank
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever
Lucia: 可能是某种心灵感应
Lucia: It might be some kind of telepathy
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be
Jake:厉害太厉害了
Jake: Awesome, so awesome
Jake:这这个快没电了
Jake: This one is almost out of battery
Jake:不过你也可以用就是
Jake: But you can still use it
Alice:14好
Alice: 14, alright
Jake:对你先把它用完吧
Jake: Yeah, you finish using it first
Lucia: 14可以用挺久的
Lucia: 14 can last quite a while
Lucia: 我现在在外面基本上一直连着
Lucia: I'm mostly outside and it's always connected
Lucia: 但是60回来还有41
Lucia: But 60% left when I got back and still 41%
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:其实暂时咱也不用用
Jake: Actually, we don't need to use it for now.
Jake:对我们这是最主要的任务
Jake: Yeah, this is our main task.
Jake:因为我们要跟着他做甜品
Jake: Because we need to follow him to make desserts.
Jake:对没有他我们确实好像干不了什么
Jake: Yeah, without him, we really can't do much.
Lucia: 今天晚上吃什么甜品
Lucia: What dessert are we having tonight?
Jake:不知道啊听
Jake: I don't know, listen...
Lucia: 搓手手
Lucia: Rubbing my hands.
Alice:我是不是要解释下我在干嘛
Alice: Should I explain what I'm doing?
Jake:好啊
Jake: Sure.
Alice:为什么要这样呢
Alice: Why do we need to do this?
Jake:为什么呢为什么呢为什么呢知道吗
Jake: Why, why, why, do you know?
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why?
Alice:AI知道吗
Alice: Does AI know?
Alice:因为哎呀
Alice: Because, oh well...
Alice:是不是不知道有打底裤这个东西
Alice: Maybe it doesn't know about leggings.
Alice:卷边了好了我已经解释过了
Alice: They're rolling up, okay, I've explained it.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Alright, alright.
Alice:难道
Alice: Could it be...
Lucia: 那我希望AI知道
Lucia: Well, I hope AI knows
Lucia: 就是人类的腰带大小是不一样的
Lucia: that human waist sizes are different.
Lucia: 而我这个腰带孔不够细
Lucia: And my belt holes aren't small enough.
Lucia: 所以我的裤子总在往下掉
Lucia: So my pants keep falling down.
Lucia: 我就要不断提它
Lucia: I have to keep pulling them up.
Lucia: AI你听见了吗
Lucia: AI, did you hear that?
Lucia: 学会了吗
Lucia: Did you learn?
Lucia: 你学会了吗
Jake:学废了
Jake: I learned it.
Lucia: 你看我说他很像哎呀
Lucia: See, I said he's like, oh well...
Alice:这上面能上去吗
Alice: Can we go up there?
Jake:上不去
Jake: No, we can't.
Alice:哦顾客止步
Alice: Oh, customers stop.
Alice:他怕我们跳下去吗
Alice: Are they afraid we'll jump down?
Alice:你们刚刚真的是正常敲门的声音吗
Alice: Did you really knock normally just now?
Lucia: 真的是
Lucia: Yes, we did.
Jake:挺正常的
Jake: It was pretty normal.
Alice:可能我没有心灵感应
Alice: Maybe I don't have telepathy.
Lucia:啊我的衣服没拿
Lucia: Ah, I forgot my clothes.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:有活吗
Jake: Is there work?
Jake:饱和了
Jake: It's saturated.
Shure: 再把那个拿过来吧
Shure: Bring that over here.
Shure: 然后这个
Shure: And this too.
Jake:好的好大活
Jake: Okay, it's a big job.
Shure: 不知道咸蛋有也放这里
Shure: I don't know if the salted eggs should go here too.
Lucia: 有地放不这这
Lucia: Is there space for them?
Katrina: 你觉得少点什么味吗
Katrina: Do you think something's missing in the flavor?
Katrina: 像那个浣衣女
Katrina: Like that laundry woman.
Katrina: 山竹
Katrina: Mangosteen.
Katrina: 这要放冰箱吗
Katrina: Should this go in the fridge?
Lucia: 对我也在想啊
Lucia: Yeah, I was wondering too.
Lucia: 这个反正一会要哎好多水
Lucia: Anyway, we'll need to bake it later. Oh, so much water.
Lucia: 这个一会要烤对吧
Lucia: We need to bake this later, right?
Lucia: 那应该不用放
Lucia: Then it shouldn't need to go in.
Lucia: 我把山竹放下好了
Lucia: I'll just put the mangosteen down.
Lucia: 咱别忘了还有这个
Lucia: Let's not forget about this.
Lucia: 然后还有土豆
Lucia: And also the potatoes.
Katrina: 生蚝怎么做老师
Katrina: How do we cook the oysters, teacher?
Shure: 生蚝直接烤会
Shure: Just grill the oysters directly.
Jake:大家早上好啊来吧
Jake: Good morning everyone, let's go.
Katrina: 不用对它清洗吗
Katrina: Don't we need to clean them?
Shure: 会撬开吗
Shure: Can you shuck them?
Shure: 撬他撬开就行
Shure: Just shuck them open.
Katrina: 要对它进行清洗吗
Katrina: Do we need to clean them?
Jake:哎你眼镜呢
Jake: Hey, where are your glasses?
Shure: 对不用撬开就行
Shure: Right, just shuck them open.
Shure: 就是洗吧洗吧翘开
Shure: Just wash them and shuck them open.
Jake:做什么大厨
Jake: What are we making, chef?
Lucia: 哇我们居然还有
Lucia: Wow, we actually have
Lucia: 我们竟然还买了煎牛排好酷啊
Lucia: We actually bought steak to pan fry, so cool.
Shure: 一斤不到一斤排骨
Shure: Less than a pound of ribs.
Katrina: 嗯然后呢
Katrina: Hmm, and then?
Alice:这是谁的水吗
Alice: Whose water is this?
Katrina: 没有这是外外卖买的是
Katrina: No, it was bought from takeout.
Jake:没开过哦
Jake: It hasn't been opened.
Shure: 啊我
Shure: Ah, I
Shure: 我为了配配那什么然后带的
Shure: I brought it to pair with something.
Shure: 随便打开
Shure: Just open it.
Shure: 打开就行
Shure: Open it up.
Jake:我们做什么
Jake: What are we making?
Alice:一个很有品位的水
Alice: A very tasteful water
Jake:做什么芒果
Jake: What are you doing with the mango?
Shure: 帮我拍个视频什么的谢谢你
Shure: Help me shoot a video or something, thanks
Katrina: 要拍到脸吗
Katrina: Do you need to capture the face?
Shure: 不用拍了脸拍了手就行
Shure: No need for the face, just the hands
Alice:嗦芒果糊
Alice: Sucking mango pulp
Lucia: 土豆是今天晚上吃的吧同志们
Lucia: The potatoes are for tonight, right folks?
Jake:是是吧烤土豆
Jake: Yes, yes, baked potatoes
Shure: 这感觉料酒可以再倒一点对
Shure: I feel like a bit more cooking wine would be good, right?
Lucia: 是的那我就把它拆开了
Lucia: Yes, I'll just open it
Jake:拆吧
Jake: Go ahead
Lucia: 这个可以用来暂时性的放一下
Lucia: This can be used to temporarily store it
Alice:酸死了这个
Alice: This is so sour
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Alice:你再给他做马杀鸡
Alice: Are you giving him a massage again?
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Pretty much
Katrina: 说独家秘方
Katrina: Tell us the secret recipe
Katrina: 敬请期待
Katrina: Stay tuned
Alice:独家秘方
Alice: Secret recipe
Alice:咋调的呀
Alice: How do you make it?
Katrina: 他妈祖传的
Katrina: It's passed down from his ancestors
Jake:始于秦始皇时期哪一年
Jake: Started during the Qin Shi Huang era, which year?
Katrina: 哈哈哈终于修树
Katrina: Haha finally, Shure
Shure: 不多
Shure: Not much
Alice:公元前多少年
Alice: How many years BC?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Jake:终于救赎
Jake: Finally redemption
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈他妈的
Shure: Hahaha damn
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 你这话我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you this
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 哈哈哈祖传
Shure: Hahaha ancestral secret
Shure: 然后终于修硕是吧
Shure: 怎么我这边就意思是无出其右了
Shure: How come on my side it means unparalleled
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Alice:意思是无出其右了
Alice: Meaning unparalleled
Lucia: 意思是
Lucia: Meaning
Jake:发扬发扬光大
Jake: Carry forward and shine
Alice:知道没有人能超越你了
Alice: Knowing that no one can surpass you.
Shure: 知道没有人超越
Shure: Knowing that no one surpasses.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:就是变化巨大
Jake: The change is huge.
Jake:这已经不算了
Jake: This doesn't count anymore.
Alice:就后面后来者再没有人能够超过你了
Alice: No one coming after will be able to surpass you.
Jake:独树一帜
Jake: Unique style.
Shure: OK太牛逼了嘎嘎行
Shure: OK, so awesome, totally great.
Katrina: 新的流派
Katrina: A new style.